Speaker 1: I don't want to spend a lot of time
on this next story, but I did want to mention it.
We have a new report which indicates that
briefing Donald Trump was the most difficult
of any president that the CIA has had to brief.
Now, anecdotally, remember that we learned
that the presidential daily briefing under
Trump was reduced to one page half. The page
was an image or a chart, and then there were like
two or three bullet points and check. This is so
funny. Business Insider reports briefing Donald
Trump as he prepared to enter the White House was
more difficult than briefing any other incoming
president. A book published by the CIA said
the publication Getting to know the president
by John Helgerson, former intelligence officer,
charted different presidents interactions
with intelligence agencies. In it,
Helgerson wrote For the intel community, the Trump
transition was far and away the most difficult
in its historical experience with briefing new
presidents Helgerson. His book was published by
the CIA for U.S. officials. The CIA says in the
book that its contents are the author's own and
do not reflect the position of the CIA. OK, yeah,
we understand that, Helgerson wrote. The only
comparable experience to Trump's transition was
that of Nixon quote. The only and imperfect analog
was the Nixon transition, he said, after Nixon
effectively declined to work with the intelligence
community and instead got his information through
an intermediary. Trump was like Nixon, suspicious
and insecure about the intelligence process. But
unlike Nixon in the way he reacted, rather than
shut the intelligence community out, Trump engaged
with it but attacked it publicly. Helgerson new
book Helgerson This book was first published in
96. It has been updated with each new president,
so imagine expert comes in and explain something.
Trump interrupts you. Trump corrects you,
Trump asserts. He knows more. And you were wrong.
Trump will publicly then attack your institution.
Sometimes he will even attack individuals from the
intelligence community. I was reading about this
and I saw a good comment written by just just
a random commenter summarizing Trump as quote
an incurious, anti-intellectual narcissist
incapable or unwilling to learn information
necessary to do the job so high on himself
that he quote knows more than the generals
and only listens to those who manage to compliment
him enough, a tactic several foreign leaders
employed to get him to pay attention for half a
second. Very apt summary. And he might win again.
Tens of millions of people want the guy back, and
that's really what should be scaring us right now